cobit 19 severely impacted the clark
county school district and forced
all students to start distance education
that was last march
but for the first time in more than a
year all grade levels finally returned
to campus
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the big day and a new issue
for some families
rolling out the red carpet the
centennial high school cheerleaders
welcome back
students i've been online for so long i
just
can't wait to meet my teachers luke
anderson is part of ccsd's final
transition group to reopen school
buildings
grades 4 5 7 8 10 and 11
joined their peers who returned last
month i was really excited to see my
friends
middle and high schools continue to
offer the hybrid model
students in class two days and remotely
the other part of the week
but for the first time in more than a
year all
elementary schools now allow in-person
instruction
five days a week i am excited for him to
go back five days a week just because he
gets the interaction
with the kids celeste tran expects the
new schedule to benefit her
kindergartner
he's getting the instruction that he
needs and i don't have to constantly you
know
make sure he's doing it at home district
data shows it's the popular option
more than 77 thousand elementary
students choosing that compared to
roughly 60 thousand
in distance education requests continue
to come in for in-person learning
causing some schools to create wait
lists i have no idea if or even when it
is that he's going to be able to go back
stephanie henry tells me she's fourth on
the list at harris elementary school
she says her first great son needs help
after falling behind he needs to be able
to go back to be able to get into like
the extra
extra tutoring while waiting for a slot
she continues to help her son with
remote learning
kristin drummond 8 news now
all schools must still follow health and
safety guidelines which is causing those
wait lists you just heard about
and that includes classroom capacity now
increasing to 75 percent
and three feet of social distancing
between those students